he's Trey Young of the Oklahoma Sooners
their point guard and he's touring the
city on behalf of two so the official
timekeeper and watch of the NBA and
gifting all the first-round draft ease
with a customized to so quick step watch
and by the way to still watches dot-com
Trey will be at the store on Fifth
Avenue at 11:30 today is that day
yeah you're gonna be signing autographs
yes sir breaking ankles not not breaking
ankles do you know what you're wearing
aside from your - so watch on draft
night what are you wearing
as far as suit something with express
did a partnership have a partnership
with express and they're gonna be
fitting me for job what color like what
are we looking at now because remember
ten years from now yeah when we show
those highlights and then we see you
walking up with a commissioner this will
be something that you guys will be
talking about everybody's on that uh-oh
I'm nervous now now you can't be nervous
is it business you'll see this is have
to see it's gonna be something something
cool okay just telling you think you'll
like it
I've seen this before where guys show up
with an all-white suit all purple yeah
maroon I can't I can't okay alright did
you announce your shoe company
affiliation no I haven't announced its
coming soon okay jay-z just took over
Puma I seen that yeah have you heard
from jay-z jay-z before really
what do you JC you say he's uh he's a
big fan of mine I mean he's one of my
Vegas okay wait a minute how does it
work or jay-z gets ahold of you in your
dorm room at Oklahoma I don't know if
you asked around that gets around oh no
he just calls you on your cell phone
yeah I mean what's it come up just a
number or this jay-z you know I didn't
drive it none of your business
yeah now I don't know I don't remember
the number but it's just a regular they
just called and you know did he want to
represent you with Roc Nation
I will they try okay I for sure okay
alright but you had to tell jay-z no I I
told the represent
could you have told you no yeah no I
didn't tell Jay Z no that I definitely I
told the represent no without the gun so
have you been to New York before
I've been New York Times okay yeah so I
like you here I like you here the
weather's been pretty nice out here yes
hot and humid like Norman Oklahoma right
very similarly what if the Knicks are
listening right now about you playing in
the garden for the next I mean the
garden is something special
I've never played in the garden that
actually out of all the invader means
I've been to and played in Staples
Center last year Berkeley is like I've
never been in the garden that's
someplace that I can't wait to play
where's the best place you ever played
in aside from home games at Oklahoma uh
highlights tables in here
I played instead was the white and every
at the background yeah just just a
history like whenever I'm playing it a
court with that much history I mean even
like to ensure like the garden like you
just have to get to put on a show you
have to play who did you grow up rooting
for NBA one in be a wise I never really
was rooting for a team I mean I grew up
in an Oklahoma saw the big Thunder fan I
went when KD and Russ was there even
before when the Oklahoma City Hornets
when Chris Paul was there I was a big
fan of Oklahoma City teams but I never I
was always a big fan of players like I
know you Steve Nash Steve Nash Allen
Iverson Chris Paul Chauncey Billups
those type of guys but you model your
game after Steve okay nice what was it
about Nash that kind of you captured
your imagination well I just think like
his overall cerebral ability he can
really pass the ball score the ball and
we our bodies are very similar I think
just overall just the the fact that
we're very much similar I think so have
you talked to him yeah I have actually
that's not that out of all the people
that I've talked to whenever I got a
text from Steve during the season I was
just I was just crazy what are you
saying he sent me a long text message I
can't remember exactly what he said but
I had to show my dad come out soon with
my dad and I
selling the phone asking like if this is
real like I didn't realize like it was
really not Betty got your number yeah
they got my number and we were texting
and we've been in contact ever since and
I've been training out in LA and he
lives out in Manhattan Beach so we've
been trying to trying to get something
to work out where we can work out
together
who else was reached reached out to um I
mean a lot of the players like like
Chris Paul I've been to a few of the
Warriors games on so I've been talking
to got like Stefan and Katie and stuff
like that so former players former
players like AI what did I say he said
some some some little bit vulgar so yeah
he talked to me he thought to me he said
first thing I do is be ready for
practice so uh practice practice you
ready to do practice huh was he joking
no I you serious a little bit so his
language is colorful nomad I mean that's
on TV he's a great guy what am i I was
one of his biggest fans but if I said
ten years ago yeah Steve Nash is gonna
text you jay-z's gonna call you
mm-hmm Steph's gonna say hello like what
would you said to all that I mean I
would have dreamed about it I would have
tried to get a goal to make it where it
happened and I would believe that it
would come true because of how much work
I put in so you're not surprised you're
here I'm not I'm not I get that question
a lot and I am I surprised about what I
did this year things like that I'm not
very surprised just because I know I'm
gonna work out with it and I expected to
do this who's a better shooter than you
better than me
I can't nobody's better than you in my
mind my confident ability uh no but I
know I got a lot of things to work on
get better at but but if I put you out
there with Klay and Steph
it'd be a battle but I feel like I would
come out and win okay
but that's but I love the confidence I
mean I would want to hear that yeah but
you know there's always that borderline
of being cocky or confident there yeah
nah I respect I respect I have a lot of
respect for a guy like Steph Klay
everybody I respect their games but I
definitely
best-looking jumpshot is who aside from
you oh it's not for me you name clay I
think I think he was perfect I think his
I mean it's textbook thanks book but
this what he impacted Steph Curry have
on you're getting rid of a shot you know
with your size to be able to get your
shot off it feels like he's he's changed
basketball I agree I agree I I was
joking with my family the other day just
about Holly this is the right time for
me to come out I mean with with Steph
changing the game a lot of the the NBA
style of game is moving to the
three-point line and spacing of the
floor
I think Steph changed the game in that
that way so I came out the the right
time that quick release oh yeah because
that's something that we didn't see
before that it's it's really quick
so how would you teach younger kids if
they're trying to emulate that quick
release well I just think it starts with
your mechanics
I mean developing development from
inside out I never really started
shooting threes until I got I got a lot
older I see my little brother does it
now he just chunks up threes it's not
not the right form stuff like that but I
started I started out at a young age
starting close working on mechanics and
then ultimately moving out and then you
can oh you can always a speed your shot
up and I try to tell people that if you
want to learn to shoot started about
three or four feet from the basket and
just get formed yeah and then move back
and then move back and then move back
and then you're gonna get to a point
where you're not strong enough to be
shooting there so then you know what
your range is yeah but guys get in bad
habits when they're younger and their
shot is not good because of that but
your dad being a former college player
probably you know gave you the
instruction of started here and move it
out here I agree in that cuz that's when
you start out young you're you're
shooting deep shots I mean it just
develop that habits and
starting started yelling and focusing on
that he's try yelling the former
Oklahoma point guard joining us on
behalf of T so the official timekeeper
and watch of the NBA it's T so yeah Tisa
t so alright the customized t so quick
step watch all the first-round draftees
will get that we had an idea can t so
come up with a watch for you to wear
during maybe warm-ups in a preseason I
know you can't wear it in the game so
could you imagine because they won't let
you wear just in warmups
I don't know just throwing it out there
Trey I mean I know you got marketing
people here with T so yeah that's an
idea that's an idea but that's on the
house I'm not gonna charge you that's
free okay yeah that's just I appreciate
it alright so by the way you can see
Trey at the T so watches calm
that'll be 5th Avenue store at 11:30
a.m. today most shots you put up in a
game high school or college with last
year fascinated 30 not like at what
point do you say maybe I'm shooting too
much um have you ever gotten to that
point yeah I've done that point ok I've
got that point and then you just keep
shooting no no I definitely don't well
the last room I got the 39 shots I look
back at the film and I was it was a suit
of layup in there come out the rim I
grabbed it I shoot it again keep doing
that I'll get three or four shots like
that so I didn't do that all the time I
probably would've been into 39 but most
points you scored in a game high school
college I had 62 twice in high school oh
my god what's that like SI shooting into
nose
yeah yeah I guess not fair I mean I
don't know but okay if you look at what
Kobe did when he put up 81 mm-hmm he had
to come back
he had to come back in that game yeah it
was a close game yeah our game I we
ended up winning by 1520 and because if
it's a close game you can continue to
show you can continue to stay in the
game too
I came I scored 62 with five minutes
left in the fourth quarter okay so you
could have conceivably gotten night 80
yeah you could have gotten on the door
there yeah so 62 and you heard from Kobe
right
yeah I actually got a signed jersey what
do you say
I just welcome to the family well whose
family NBA family
oh okay I think I didn't know oh okay
yeah how many jerseys do you have I
don't have any jay-z's surprisingly okay
well you'll you'll beginning yeah you'll
be asking I'm sure yeah well okay Oh
explain to me why these big guys are
going probably going first in it why are
you gonna be seventh eighth ninth in the
draft and not first second or third if
today's NBA is about three-point I don't
know could be teen fit could be teen fit
yeah but in there a place for you
anywhere yeah I mean if we're going
based off just couldn't Phoenix use you
I think yeah okay but I mean you never
know
are you more valuable than Marvin Bagley
or DeAndre Aten in today's NBA I think
so
sure because they regard the garden yeah
play is in the all right
a lot of greats have done this now I'm
gonna give you the highlights this is
what they're saying about you going into
the draft yeah this is actual draft
profile stuff all right and then I'm
gonna let you read the negative ones
about you all right Trey young point
guard Oklahoma unique ability to
generate offense off the dribble now if
you disagree or want to add anything you
let me know here yeah I comfortable
pulling up on a beat from NBA range can
break down opponents in space and get
into the paint you all right with that
adept at using ball screens slithery
getting downhill round to pick able to
make the right read and find open
teammate good with that yep skill based
finisher uses floaters and creates
angles for himself around the basket
despite lack of vertical explosiveness
yeah you do you have lack of vertical
explosiveness
that's something I've got a lot
what's your vertical I don't I don't
know yeah I don't know I really don't
know under under 30
oh no not under there come on oh my god
say under 30 I don't know I'm thinking
maybe you're like like right at 30 no no
like Paulie can you show that tray what
under 30 looks like a vertical here this
is what under 30 so ready oh yeah no
you're more than about 30 you're above
30 my man no no no no we're meant to
disrespect you so how good a dunker are
you I'm pretty good dunker now like what
can you do
I offer love like well you yeah if I
said you could win the three-point
contest or the dunk contest of you
three-point no you want to win the dunk
now I want to win the three-point yeah
but I expect you to win the three-point
nobody expects you to win the dunk this
is all about marketing yeah once again
you get the T so and then you know you
have maybe like five watches oh you know
what time is it yeah oh yeah all right
here we go
led the country in usage rate 38.5
shouldering a remarkable workload
particularly a true fret for true
freshmen wore down a bit season went on
but sustained run of success and what
you did for the offense in Oklahoma all
right you're fine whatever right these
are negatives Trey Young is going to
read about his draft profile here we go
here we go all right shots
SOT oh wait he's got a bullet pointed
yeah okay
yeah shot selection has to be reined in
falls back on launching threes when
other things aren't working okay is that
true falls back on launching threes uh I
disagree okay but uh because I like to
fall back on my three but that's because
I'm getting back down to the other end
of the floor like I'm already going back
to play defense oh you know it's going
in yeah yeah so maybe that's what you're
doing
yeah I guess okay thank you sometimes
all right here we go okay last idea of
physical tools
six-two these physical limitations
become apparent once he gets to the rim
okay
I mean I see I mean I see guys like
Chris Paul get to the rim get to the
paint all the time okay all right so you
disagree with that one too I mean I
think you you overthink that okay in my
opinion okay all right below average
defensively had to be hidden at times it
will be a guy that opposing offenses
will attack okay I mean yeah this year I
definitely felt like I gave the people
that I mean just an opportunity to have
that judgment because of the way I
played this year okay do you think you
could stop me
yeah you do yeah like if I got ten tries
at the top of the King mmm do I score on
you mmm-hmm really yeah
okay I'm not to see you again now yeah
well that's the world it's true you got
you got no I'm gonna do it again
don't leave me open okay cuz I'm
automatic okay cuz I'm not afraid okay
okay here we go guys you know okay what
else he is also not big enough to stop
anyone else on the court okay
we've established that that you're
probably not able to if you can't stop
me you know okay
all right what are you gonna do when
LeBron comes down the lane that's a good
answer
okay got any more negativity there one
more okay I don't see it with him he's
erratic with the ball he's a teaser
volume shooter I have concerns on him
okay wow that sounds like someone's
that's a hater right there but you know
what I would save that in you know in
five years you look back on what people
said about you you know drew brees Aaron
Rodgers JJ Watt they all wanted to keep
it as motivation because it's not just
getting drafted mm-hmm it's after you
get drafted is when it really starts
there
but I think people are focusing on what
you don't do yeah and you do so many
other things your ability to see the
floor you know they didn't want to
compare you to Steph Curry and that's
not fair to you
mm-hm because you're I think you see the
floor better than Steph does coming into
the league you're a better Handler
better passer I think that he I would
look at him as a a more consistent
scorer I think you had that ability
early on I don't know what game it was
when I came in I saw you your first 40
point game yeah and I came in I said I
don't know who the dude is but the guy
can score with anybody in the country
but then I didn't know if you were gonna
be able to hold up and that's thirty
games now you got to hold up for 82 and
then the playoff series yeah so that's
that's a big concern but I hate when
they they don't focus on what you do
well because you know the ability to
find an open teammate yeah it's not
something you can teach yeah what I
think when I look back at it I just I
just think people forget how hard
leaving the country in any stat ya is
and leaving it in two other main
categories I mean ever been done so I
just think people just I don't know what
they forget or they don't understand how
like that that just doesn't happen and
so I'm I'm fine because I know I put in
the work and effort so it's all gonna
pay off man yeah and what people don't
understand and Iverson will be the first
to tell you this when you have to be the
man every single night so whatever gym
you went into whatever team you face
their best guy is on you their defensive
philosophy is based off you and you
still have to get up volume you have to
get up shots if your team has a chance
to win that pressure as a freshman
that's pretty heavy
ya know I mean it definitely was I knew
what I was getting into when I want to
chose Oklahoma over Kentucky or Kansas
those who the other two yeah those are
the other two that I was I was down to
so did you tell Calipari you weren't
going to Kentucky yeah I made it I made
all the phone calls oh you did I mean
other phone calls who was tougher to
tell Bill Self or John Keller I coach
tough why I mean because self I didn't
recruit me since I was a sophomore in
high school
so it was just tough and he's an
Oklahoma guy he's from Oklahoma big 12
country I was gonna see him at least
twice a year no boy so that was that was
tough did he remind you at all this past
season that you should have gone to
Kansas oh no he did it he did it I mean
they had a really good team obviously
and went to the Final Four so they he
was good he's straight young and joining
us on behalf of T so the official
timekeeper and watch of the NBA all the
first-round draft picks get customized T
so quick step watches you can go to T
cell watches calm to learn more check
out the entire NBA collection and he'll
be at the T so Fifth Avenue store at
11:30 a.m. today good luck with the
Knicks so we'll get an opportunity to
see we'll see you a Thursday great to
see you thank you for joining us for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]